[Music]
when NBC decided to create a spinoff
from their hit series the blacklist they
had the perfect star in mind to headline
the series famke janssen after making a
debut in the show's third season her
character Susan Hargrave became the
focus of the blacklist redemption if you
think you recognize her from somewhere
it's probably because you've seen
Janssen in one of her dozens of film and
television roles he is wife Susan from
the blacklist looked so familiar Golden
Eye Johnson got her start at the model
in the late 80s but in the early 90s she
decided to transition to acting she soon
landed small roles on shows like Star
Trek The Next Generation and in films
such as father and sons but her big
break came in the 1995 James Bond film
Goldeneye where she played the sinister
Russian agent a Zegna on a top Jennifer
gave now on the top on the top on the
top the character has become a fan
favorite consistently ranking among the
best Bond girls ever house on Haunted
Hill following the success of Goldeneye
Jansen was offered a number of roles one
of the most high-profile was opposite
Geoffrey Rush as one half of the
eccentric a couple running the show in
the 1999 horror remake house on Haunted
Hill the flick was a critical punching
bag but has become a bit of a cult
favorite anyway x-men no matter what
Johnson does in her career
there are many fans who will always see
her was Jean Grey from 20th Century
Fox's x-men franchise since 2000 Johnson
has played the redhead mutant psychic
multiple times including the original
x-men x2x men United in 2003 and x-men
The Last Stand in 2006 where she was
killed off
she later appeared in 2013's the
Wolverine as a figment of Logan's
tortured imagination but thanks to some
time-travel shenanigans he was returned
to life for realsies in 2014 x-men Days
of Future past
nip/tuck a year after x-2 hits theaters
Johnson landed a recurring role in the
second season of FX's medical drama
nip/tuck the primary antagonist of that
season transgender life coach Ava Moore
became a key recurring character
returning in season six for a major arc
hide-and-seek one of Johnson's stranger
roles was in a psychological thriller
hide-and-seek where she played opposite
Robert De Niro her part is family friend
dr. Katherine Carson wasn't large but
she figured prominently in each of the
films five different endings and u-thor
the x-men movies were hard to keep
straight taken 20th Century Fox
apparently didn't want to let go of
Johnson following the original x-men
trilogies conclusion so they cast her as
Leonor many mills and they're taken
theories in 2008 she played the wife of
Liam Neeson's Bryan Mills whose daughter
is taken captive bad move poles are a
very particular set of skills skills I
have acquired over a very long career
skills that make me a nightmare for
people like you in 2012 she returned in
a larger role this time the victim of a
revenge kidnapping Neeson of course
saves her - too bad he couldn't get the
job done in 2015 taken 3 where it's her
life that gets taken at the start of the
film one of these days one of Johnson's
characters will eventually survivor
trilogy Hansel and Gretel witch hunters
in between taken installments Johnson's
garden senator grant Waite Mariel in
2013 Hansel and Gretel witch hunters are
we imagining of the classic fairy tale
the film wasn't exactly a critical
favorite but it did well enough at the
box office to warrant a sequel whether
or not a Johnson will be involved hasn't
been announced yet even though her
character died don't count her out
Hemlock Grove in 2013 Johnson shifted
away from movies and back into
television in a big way
starring in a leading role in the
groundbreaking Netflix series Hemlock
Grove
which was one of the first of Digital
Extremes show
to ever receive an Emmy nomination he
played Olivia Godfrey head of the
Sinister Godfrey Institute for
biomedical technologies for all three
seasons before the show ended in 2015
[Music]
young how to get away with murder before
landing the lead role in blacklist
Redemption Johnson took another juicy
role in the hit series how to get away
with murder
playing Attorney rothlo a former friend
and lover of Viola Davis as lead
character Annalise Keating still
smarting from their breakup years ago
IVA finally got over Annalise in season
three and walked away whether or not she
ever returns may depend on how long the
black lift redemption stays on the air
thanks for watching click the loop icon
to subscribe to our youtube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
your love thing
[Music]